[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
sport l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département tout de
suite le sommaire de votre magazine golf
elle cent unième édition de l'open de
france a livré son verdict ce dimanche
soir sur les greens du golf national de
saint quentin en yvelines c'est le
britannique tommy fleetwood 26 ans 4e du
dernier us open qui a remporté la
compétition
le premier français arrivent troisièmes
tous les détails dans quelques instants
du golfe encore avec la ryder cup 2018
le skipper français armel le cléac'h
vainqueur du dernier vendée globe sera
l'ambassadeur de cette coupe du monde du
golf à 50 ans du bim en septembre de
l'année prochaine de l'iran posé trois
questions cricket lyon ce club a
organisé ce dimanche de juillet dans le
parc du château de thoiry un match
caritatif entre les équipes de thoiry de
saint-omer cette dernière était composé
de réfugiés afghans irakiens aux
pakistanais les informations sont a su
dans ce magazine
gros plan à présent sur les principaux
résultats du week-end dans le
département et en parlera notamment de
golf
[Musique]
je vous disais dans les titres l'open de
france de golf se dérouler la semaine
dernière sur les greens du golf national
de saint quentin en yvelines après
quatre jours de suspense et de
rebondissements c'est finalement le
natif de sources porte en angleterre
tommy fleetwood qui est devenu le
nouveau roi de france le bilan sportif
de l'épreuve
nicolas dandy pour les images c'est
l'homme en forme du moment il a prouvé
sur les greens du golf national tommy
fleetwood de 26 ans 4e du dernier us
open a remporté la 101e édition de
l'open de france
pour sa cinquième apparition à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la première
depuis 2010 le fantasque britannique
totalise un score de moins 12 au total
avec une carte de 66 soit cinq coups
sous le par le dimanche
je pense que c'était vraiment important
de bien jouer cette semaine
tout le monde a joué un très bon niveau
pour avoir un bon résultat
le parcours était très agréable et cela
m'a permis d'avoir un swing très
performant un swing qui lui a permis de
devenir le premier anglais remporté
l'open de france depuis 2007 et la
victoire de grimm storm
une performance saluée par les milliers
de spectateurs venus pour profiter du
spectacle le dimanche je pense c'est un
joueur dont on entendra beaucoup parler
dans le futur magnifique
super joueur c'est une génération qui
arrive et ils sont super traverse du
côté des tricolores en attendait le
meilleur français au classement mondial
alexander levy où l'imprévisible victor
dubuisson c'est finalement michael
lorenzo vera qui a réalisé la meilleure
performance des bleus sur le parcours de
l'albatros avec un moins huit au total
un score qui lui permet de terminer
troisième du tournoi est de se qualifier
pour le british open une première pour
le basque de 32 ans qui avait du bon
golf situé 2 voilà toto qui a bien connu
une belle partie en plus ce dimanche
avec les weston ça c'était cool
santander on joue bien et deux donc
c'est un bon ça fait bien plaisir
puisque vraiment là les gens étaient au
repos depuis le début de la semaine
chaque fois que toujours des mots
gentils toujours demandé à mon frère
après cette troisième place michael
lorenzo-vera vous et succéder à thomas
levet l'année prochaine sur le golf
national
le dernier vainqueur français à l'open
de france et et en 2011 on continue à
parler de l'open de france de golf vous
l'avez peut-être remarqué si vous êtes
passés sur les greens de saint quentin
en yvelines
la compétition a pris un nouvel essor
cette année une nouvelle organisation
nouveau parking rénovation de l'hôtel
des joueurs de renom tout cela grâce un
nouveau sponsor hasek a rejeté plusieurs
millions d'euros dans le rendez vous
coup de projecteur un montage de xavier
jaglin l'open de france 2010 être entre
dans une nouvelle ère le tournoi est
passé cette année sous le pavillon du
groupe d'investisseurs chinois à chennai
l'entreprise investit dans leur rendez
vous saint quentinois et la dotation est
passé à plus de 7 millions de dollars le
double par rapport à 2016 nous
sommes-nous fédération ravid cette
évolution nous sommes ravis de cette
montée en puissance de notre peine
nationale et puis on croise les doigts
pour ça se poursuit dans le tout les
tentes du terme
pour cette édition 2010 est la
compétition a tiré des têtes d'affiché
françaises comme alexander levy au
victor dubuisson et des stars
internationales comme jeunes rameaux
tommy fleetwood sur le plan sportif le
rendez vous a également intégré les
rolex series les meilleurs tournois
européens
c'est un superbe événement voilà on a la
chance de faire partie des plus grands
tournant européen donc pour nous
français on est très heureux d'avoir un
tournoi comme ça il a appris en
dimension c'est déjà c'était déjà un
gros tournoi mais là c'est encore plus
gros je pense que c'est vraiment voilà
une des meilleures éditions cons et
qu'on ait eu à jouer au niveau du décor
les spectateurs ont pu voir du
changement nouveau parking nouveau
centre de presse rénovation de l'hôtel
les prémices d'une organisation
millimétrée pour la ryder cup qui se
déroulera sur l'albatros en septembre
c'est vrai qu'à une année de la ryder
cup ça nous permet de faire des tests en
grandeur nature
c'est vrai qu'en termes de volume un
open de france n'a pas grand chose à
voir avec une ryder cup il faut
quasiment tout multiplié par dix mais en
tout cas ça nous permet de faire des
tests
le parcours s'est mis lui aussi aux
dimensions de la ryder cup après
quelques modifications 2016 les greens
sont aujourd'hui parfaitement terminé
pour pouvoir accueillir les meilleurs
joueurs du monde c'est une parcours très
bon spectateurs on peut on peut foyer on
peut voir tout ça c'est très bon balle
parfois est magnifique
franchement il améliore ils ont beaucoup
amélioré par la fois d'avant là rien à
dire il est vraiment superbe
rendez vous l'année prochaine pour la
dernière répétition générale sur l'open
de france nouvelle génération
quelques mois avant de recevoir près de
200000 spectateurs pour la ryder cup
on en parlait dans le reportage
précédent la ryder cup 2018 l'équivalent
de la coupe du monde du golf sera donc
programmée du vendredi 28 septembre
dimanche 30 septembre sur les greens du
golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines
plus de 700 millions de personnes
devraient regarder la compétition devant
leur télévision sur le parcours de
l'albatros ce sont près de 70000
personnes qui viendront encourager les
joueurs tous les jours comme on peut le
voir sur ces images tournées à la ryder
cup 2016 pour soutenir cet événement
exceptionnel l'organisation a décidé
d'attribuer un parrain prestigieux armel
le cléac'h vainqueur du dernier vendée
globe
nous lui avons posé trois questions
hélas beaucoup fait déjà joué avec la
météo le terrain sur l'eau en tire des
bords bien des fois où il faut savoir
aussi et pas forcément aller directement
vers le trou et puis travailler aussi le
coup d'après on fait souvent des mauvais
coups des bons coups en golf il faut
savoir switcher dans la tête pour rester
concentré sur la suite du parcours et
pas forcément changé d'état d'esprit
bah c'est souvent le cas en battant
notamment contourner en solitaire parce
qu'on est tout seul contre soi-même
contre les éléments et le parcours et
golf il ya beaucoup de points communs
[Musique]
c'est un honneur déjà pour représenter
la ryder cup c'est le plus grand
événement de golf au monde qui aura lieu
en france l'année prochaine on va
espérer avoir justement le public
français qui s'y intéressent énormément
parce que c'est l'un des plus grands
événements sportifs au monde avec les
meilleurs européens les meilleurs
américains et ça va être pour moi
l'occasion de tests sur le parcours de
voir ces joueurs là jouer les uns contre
les autres avec une ambiance de folie
ce sera l'occasion pour moi de bouger
tiff qui sera là à la route du rhum
quelques semaines après de voir un petit
peu l'ambiance et et la compétition de
très très haut niveau
j'avais suivi
des deux derniers entre dernière édition
notamment avenida qu'il y avait eu
fameux miracle de me dire vous savez t1
mon super à suivre à la télé déjà hélas
de le vivre l'année prochaine en réel va
sur le sur le code national ça va être
un moment génial
l'essai comme d'autres ambassadeurs qui
vont être sûrement nommé dans les
semaines et les mois qui viennent c'est
essayer de promouvoir l'événement en
france aujourd'hui le golfe restent
malheureusement un sport peut-être pas
assez médiatisé pour diverses raisons et
au contraire c'est vraiment un
il ya beaucoup de choses à promouvoir
par rapport à 7 ce sport qui est
incroyable difficile de très haut niveau
et j'espère que d'ici un an et demi on
va réussir à donner envie à beaucoup de
français de suivre cet événement en
france on quitte cette large page golf
il y avait également du baseball ce
week-end les cougars de montigny le
bretonneux se sont déplacés sur le
terrain de mme hughes barracuda ce
dimanche pour le compte de la 11e
journée du championnat de première
division et ils montrent un sont
repartis avec deux grosses défaites dans
leurs valises c'est un dans le premier
match et 10 à 3 dans le second au
classement montigny le bretonneux reste
en quatrième position avec un bilan de
11 victoires et 11 défaites l'équipe
semble bien parti pour accrocher les
playoffs de fin de saison
direction maintenant les terrains de
rugby changement d'entraîneur à la tête
de l'équipe senior du plaisir rugby club
jean miss coach du 15 plaisir wa depuis
deux ans et son adjoint fun avec jardé
ont été remercié par les dirigeants
malgré la montée du club en fédérale 2
la saison prochaine et un parcours
historique en championnat de france avec
un quart de finale de fédérale 3 les
dirigeants n'ont pas annoncé
officiellement les raisons de cette
séparation club c'est la décision
interne qui a été privilégiée gens me
sera remplacé par sébastien roch à lille
l'entraîneur des juniors a plaisir à la
saison dernière 1-1 mots de judo à
présent la superstar teddy riner double
champion olympique et huit fois champion
du monde dans la catégorie des plus de
100 kg pourrait débarquer dans les
yvelines
l'homme de 28 ans qui mesure deux mètres
04 aurait présenté au président du paris
saint germain
nasser el rey là il fit un projet de
section de judo au sein du club parisien
quinze années après la disparition dans
l'ancienne structure le dossier pourrait
se mettre en place après son contrat
avec levallois qui court jusqu'en 2018
une fois n'est pas coutume nous allons
parler de cricket un sport originaires
des anciennes colonies britanniques dans
ce magazine
le lion ce club a organisé le ce
dimanche de juin juillet dans le parc du
château de thoiry un match caritatif
entre les équipes de thoiry et de
saint-omer une équipe de saint-omer
composé principalement de ré fut
j afghans et irakiens ou pakistanais un
reportage de nicolas landry et
d'haussmann vanguard s ils sont afghans
irakiens ou pakistanais ses joueurs
composent l'équipe déclic et star de
saint-omer réfugié en france ils ont
commencé ce sport depuis leur plus jeune
âge
c'est le cas de samir ait said en
afghanistan quand je suis petit et j'ai
regardé dans la télé cricket a beaucoup
d gère mon frère mon grand frère et
léger avec des mines nationales
afghanistan et à j'ai joué avec elle un
petit peu un dépôt après je comprends
bien truquée après j'aime cricket j'ai
pris là bas quand j'étais vite chercher
j'espère ans là bas et je suis venu ici
en france j'ai choisi rakic est équipé
centenaire en jean a présenté là-bas au
score à l'entraînement à l'abandon les
semaines on les semaines pour une fois
c'est bien un sport une passion pour ces
joueurs un match caritatif organisé par
le lions ce club centenaire joue ce jour
là face à l'équipe de cricket de thoiry
quand on est experte et quand on est
étranger dans un pay le sport se joue un
rôle important pour réunir des gens des
communautés entre eux donc c'est déjà
les différentes communautés chacun a sa
propre culture et le cricket c'est un
moyen de faire mélange de communauté je
trouvais les brûler un bonne équipe et
les amants qu'un poids entraînements
parce que j'ai tendu il n'a pas de
terrain dans ici en france pour ça
il ay la mangue un gros entraînements
sinon il ya les bonnes équipes
nos fusils et le jo bien avec
l'étiquette star de saint-omer vont
devoir continuer à s'entraîner pour
renforcer le collectif
ils sont en attente d'une réponse de la
mairie pour obtenir un terrain et
s'entraîner dans de meilleures
conditions
si vous êtes un fan de foot us eco les
super bowl vous font vibrer chaque année
à la télévision ouvrez bien vos oreilles
la campagne de recrutement a débuté chez
les templiers d'elancourt pour la saison
de football américain 2017 2018 il y
aura des sections pour les moins de 16
ans et les seniors il pourrait y avoir
également une équipe pour les moins de
14 ans comme pour tout sport il faut un
certificat médical pour pratiquer cette
discipline sur les terrains du complexe
sportif europe on écoute le directeur
sportif des templiers d'elancourt
frederick henderson pour faire tant le
portier temple et ja faut vouloir venir
la première chose après c'est un pro
beaucoup c'est un sport nouveau donc il
faut apprendre presse un sport qui allie
stratégie à vitesse agilité et force et
des profils de sportive vraiment très
différent tout le monde peut trouver ça
parce qu'on soit petit rapide ou plutôt
plutôt gros et un peu d'eau du on vous
trouvera une petite place et non c'est
vraiment juste venir et puis avant la
volonté d'apprendre et et tout se
passera bien
c'est la fin de ce statut de sport merci
d'avoir suivi très belle soirée sur tv
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]